total square is simply the densest
collection of life scientists in the
known universe
it's that culture of faculty
entrepreneurs that's what really drove
Kendall's war there was a lot of courage
people really were willing to follow the
science take risk I thought one day
people will be able to work on cancer at
the molecular level this was new
technology at a world historic level man
had the ability to make a biological
organism that may not have ever appeared
before in the biological Kingdom this
country this community has not decided
that we should go ahead with this
research you've got to see it in the
shadow of the atomic bomb they kept
worrying that there was an atomic bomb
hidden away in modern biology the mayor
of Cambridge became quite alarmed
visions of cloned creatures infecting us
the worst comes to worst we could have a
major disaster on our hands it was a
real Wild West moment it was really the
birth of an industry 30 40 years ago
scientists tended not to think about the
commercial aspects of what they were
doing today everyone does when I have an
idea for a new company I can go across
the hall and I can say it has this been
tried do you know an investor I can talk
to will you be on my board all the
medicine is getting rethought in terms
of the fundamental causes of disease
things that were death sentences aren't
any more that kind of revolution doesn't
occur very often in history to have had
the opportunity to live through all of
that
as a wonder
you
[Music]